there's always a lot going on that we
don't have time to get to on the air but
there's something
specific going on behind the scenes
right now that we did feel we should
tell you about
so on monday of this week we received a
from a source a collection of
confidential documents related to the
biden family
we believe those documents are authentic
they're real and they're damning
at the time we received them our my
executive producer justin wells and i
were in los angeles preparing to
interview tony babilinski about the
biden's business dealings in china
ukraine and other countries
so we texted a producer in new york and
we asked him to send those documents to
us in la and he did that
so monday afternoon of this week he
shipped those documents overnight to
california with a large national carrier
a brand name company
that we've used you've used countless
times with never a single problem
but the biden documents never arrived in
los angeles
tuesday morning we received word from
the shipping company that our package
had been
opened and the contents were missing the
documents had disappeared
now to its credit the company took this
very seriously and immediately began a
search
they traced the envelope from the moment
our producers dropped it off
in manhattan on monday all the way to 3
44 a.m
yesterday morning that's when an
employee at a sorting facility
in another state noticed that our
package was open
and empty apparently it had been opened
so the company's security team
interviewed
every one of its employees who touched
the envelope we sent
they searched the plane and the trucks
that carried it they went through the
office in new york where our producer
dropped that package off they combed the
entire
cavernous sorting facility they used
pictures of what we had sent
so that searchers would know what to
look for they went far and beyond
but they found nothing those documents
have vanished
as of tonight the company has no idea
and no working theory even
about what happened to this trove of
materials documents that are directly
relevant to the presidential campaign
just six days from now we spoke to
executives at that company a few hours
ago
they seemed baffled and deeply bothered
by this
and so are we